[Musique]
à mi mai le prêt de la vie si tous qu'on
est astucieux belle
johnny c'est le plus sérieux ça vous
invite à jouer
aujourd'hui il suffit de vouloir devenir
has amis
[Musique]
ça va mieux et toi et bah écoutez je
crois qu'il faut dire la vérité à tous
nos amis tout quand quand toute l'équipe
et moi même nous avons fêté un événement
intérieur à notre petit groupe et nous
sommes dans une forme s'expliquait pas
des gens qui m'ont plumage au sénat
permet à axa marie ève assiette
bon bah disons oui est-ce qu'on joue au
jeu 11e du pays où le ponthou oui j'ai
eu fabrice j'ai perdu du poids plume
savais que je n'arriverais pas
l'interrompre parce que dans l'état où
il est il est quasiment un fort exprime
très content il a bu une limonade
spéciale qui le met dans un état c'est
vrai en tout cas encore et balle
exactement
allons voyons monde à l'envers et ben
faleh ce que tu fais oui tembo le jeu
géographique le jus géographie soyons
sérieux
oui trois indications le contour du pays
le drapeau ici et enfin bon le dans la
langue du pays voilà bon alors je
commence par le contour du pays voilà
c'est pas trop difficile c'est je ne
sais pas ce que c'est aujourd'hui à 10
dont harry ah bah ça je crois que je
sais c'est pointu c'est assez pointu
c'est quoi la capitale se trouve ici
comme un point au bord de l'eau c'est au
nord de la capitale frêche oui au bord
de la mer alors le drapeau le drapeau on
va le découvrir ensemble
là au moins ça c'est assez facile et
enfin peut-être plus délicat bonjour
dans la langue de ce pays
shalom je suis un oiseau jégo dichal
oiseaux salom fait alors attendons c'est
facile c'est assez facile vous
réfléchissez encore quelques petites
secondes regardez bien l'ensemble de
tout cela la carte géographique que vous
voyez ici le drapeau pour ceux qui n'ont
pas la couleur et blanc avec des bandes
bleues ainsi que l'étoile qui est bleu
et bonjour dans la langue du pays c'est
shalom bon ça suffit je pense que vous
avez trouvez maintenant il s'agit
d'israël dont vous voyez la carte le
drapeau d'israël et shalom en hébreu
voilà ce tte faisable cinq ans oui et
faisant cette eau potable
je sens que je vais devoir me retirer va
dans le jardin sont ajoutés les haïtiens
vivent
je vais préparer le jeu suivant à nice
comme d'habitude ok je pars à dos divan
jarry bonjour il allait bien alors un
des deux c'est le jouet des conneries
oui mais ça me prend je connais bien
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui alors le point
commun on l'appelle fabrice la banque
ayant rappelé la dre fui après nous
écouter alors il ne faut pas me
bousculer au japon où la la la la la
pas de bousculade intempestives jeu mais
n'a pas vu traîner piquant bull mon pic
en boule
non je n'ai pas vu aujourd'hui non c'est
pas le nom rapide et la wii
j'espère que je ne dérange personne
bassit une bavarde pas qu'une dérange
rappelle sans rentrer dans mac os qui
est le point commun
alors je le rappelle brièvement tout
cancan belbel et pousse moussu sont soit
des objets soient des choses différentes
tout le problème consiste à savoir quel
est le point qui les réunit quel est
leur point com com voilà ça joue on y
voit mal voilà tout quand tu comment je
commence à en faire une excuse m'a dit
ok ça arrive c'est la même façon alors
voilà je suis quelque chose dont tu as
besoin quand tu voyages
quand tu voyages en chemin de fer bien
sûr en avion ou en bateau
quand je dis que tu as besoin de moi je
ne veux pas dire que tu m'as emporte
avec toi non ça non tu manques prendre
comme on dit basset c'est grâce à moi
que tu sais exactement où tu vas aller
tu vois pas où tu vas passer si tu as
muret et à quelle heure tu vas arriver à
je dois te dire que je suis très très
régulier et et on peut dire que c'est
grâce à moi et à tous mes semblables que
le monde entier
pardon est à ta disposition
[Rires]
tu vas voir avec moi c'est que je
représente
c'est une chose qui est en moi que je
possède naturellement depuis toujours ou
d'ailleurs et que j'espère bien garder
très longtemps
c'est une chose qui est un élément
essentiel de mener les gosses à toutes
les femmes voudraient en avoir une comme
la mienne je reconnus qui se surveillent
du matin au soir pour y arriver il faut
attention à ce qu'ils mangent et boivent
elle fonda gymnastique
elle se couche de bonheur elle surveille
leur poids mon dieu j'ai encore pris 300
g 10 telle folie
mon dieu ce soir je ne mangerai que la
moitié d'une biscotte
et bien moi / fabrice je suis
naturellement comme ça je me contente de
ne pas faire d'excès et chacun peut voir
que le résultat est étonnant
tiens bien fait je crois comment va-t-il
dauphiné mais pour être plus sûr
j'aimerais entendre la version 2 pouces
ont subi oui abah abah est noir ou la
laub a aujourd'hui je suis quelque chose
de très inattendu c'est vrai c'est que
oui je suis quelque chose de
scientifique a vraiment quelque chose
qui n'existait pas il y à 100 ans mais
maintenant qu'on a découvert et qu'on
utilise
on ne peut plus se passer de moi
d'ailleurs c'est bien simple je
n'existerait pas si je n'existais pas
ben il n'y aurait pas de quatre amis on
ne reconnaîtrait pas le tombeau visage
par exemple fabrique servage en somme il
n'y aurait pas de télévision voilà oui
je vais encore donné une indication très
précieuse tout seul je ne servirait à
rien il faut qu'on soit très nombreux
pour être qu'il très très nombreux il
faut être 625 ou 819 tu te rends compte
ça y est pas si tu as bien compris mon
explique à cesser si tu as bien qu'on
sait pouces mais aussi maintenant je
crois que je sais en effet c'est très
intéressant où ils rapido je trouvais
retrouver où il ouvrait bien tu ne dis
rien
wang bon je crois qu'il s'agit tout
simplement comme point commun et je
pense que vous l'avez deviné de la ligne
en effet nous avons la ligne les lignes
aériennes les lignes maritimes et cetera
ça c'était pour tous quand ils jolie
femme a soin de cultiver sa ligne pour
rester mazuel et oui bell bell est enfin
sur le plan scientifique bien je ne sois
pas très calé je crois que la télévision
effectivement est en 625 ligne et même
il ya eu aussi de 819 commencent à
disparaître je crois enfin je suis pas
très calé en sciences j'espère je ne
crains c'est ça mais moi c'est tout à
fait exact
je te remercie rapidos un jeu vous aurez
vite et scientifique serait une bonne
chose
bon et bien changé ou de sciences vie on
veut enfin je vais préparer le g1000 cas
alors nous passons de la science alors
et voilà exactement alors j'ai vu un
bras depuis 6 à 3 elles bon alors là
c'est à nous et c'est à nous maintenant
mais alors je vais te dire il ya un
miracle extraordinaire et j'ai mon stylo
au combat alors là tu as fait des
progrès ah oui alors tu vas au tableau
si tu veux bien alors je vais essayer de
te faire deviner c'est difficile un mot
non c'est pas très difficile c'est pas
très difficile non sabah et
l'orthographe tu es sûr de toi je crois
je crois que ça va aller jv ba ba mon
p'tit alain alors tu vas au tableau oui
je suis bon alors c'est un mot en dix
lettres
aïe non mais il est pas difficile d
beaucoup ça quand même un beau coup ben
oui un mobile est ça commence par quoi
alors la première c'est un m
je sais pas pourquoi mais je le sens pas
bien moi je ne sais pas si je vais
gagner là alors je fais une deux trois
can 5 6 7 8 pour les lettres qui ment
bing nous sommes d'accord on finit par
quoi on par un oeuf ou
au bas du dos oui alors voilà alors
maintenant je t'écoute
comme d'habitude alors c'est une fleur
non non c'est pas une c'est un animal ah
oui c'est un animal c'est un alim
as tu vas tu as trouvé tout de suite oui
enfin ça c'est pas très difficile est ce
que c'était un gros animal 97 à petit un
tout petit en général pousse me suis tu
adores les animaux qui viennent
d'afrique le reste c'est un animal qui
vient d'afrique non non non à l'ailé il
est dans la forêt ici en europe on en
trouve en mary oui oui oui c'est un
animal qui va très vite
eux dont il va pas très vite non joue il
est pétri les petits vous dit est ce que
c'est un insecte
non j'ai pas un à cinq fois l'insecte
est ce que c'est un ami mais est-ce
qu'il est joli
will et les jolies dans son genre tu c
est dans son genre oui il est enfin pour
moi il est il est palais est ce que tu
veux que je te donne la troisième lettre
et que ça m'arrangerait parce qu'on
rêverait que là je vois pas du tout
alors la troisième lettre c'est un elle
à elle rit voilà et je vais encore donné
un petit élément supplémentaire s écrie
weeks as écrit en deux mots est ce qu'un
trait d'union oui un petit trait d'union
est un trait d'union oui
aie aie aie d'animal gentil a dit don
oui mais alors là ça n'irait pas parce
que m avec un mail ici je verrais bien
avec un trait d'union et un mille pattes
et wiba venait à trouver un mille pattes
bon alors je crois qu'il est inutile de
lui faire le moindre reproche ça ne
servirait strictement à rien mais c'est
le pauvre pouces moussu n'a aucune
notion de l'orthographe mille pattes
tu trouves qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment
de pâtes et que ça ne vaut pas la peine
de mettre un s à la fin attachement à
banon ah bah non c'est ça alors lylat je
crois qu'il serait préférable de mettre
en s1 parce qu'elles sont nombreuses
en réalité d'ailleurs je crois qu'il n'y
en a pas mille enfin non c'est ce que
j'allais dire justement alors mis parce
que ça je le savais ça s'écrit comme ça
moi on met un trait d'union ici il ne
sait pas si j'écris très bien et le pat
démarre la paix à 2t lutté mais bien
entendu il faut le et le n avait que
j'ai oublié bien j'ai bien sûr à tous
qu'elle renonce à t'apprendre
l'orthographe c'est le fut par ses gains
je viens il n'a pas mille pattes c'est
une erreur de croire ça qu'il a mille
pattes n'y en a exactement tu sais
combien non je sais pas je vais te
l'apprendre il a 42 pâtes oui et a
beaucoup âgés beaucoup en face est pas
vilain j'en ai vu un qui est passé à
côté de moi dans la forêt il avait 21
une patte d'un côté vingt-et-une patte
de l'autre jusqu'à 40 de voix là et ça
j'en suis sûr
c'est tout ce que tu veux murs et où
malgré tout c'est bon tout ça je pense
que c'est pas si mal que ça et je la
soutiens
oui abri qu'est-ce qu'il ya tout
complété le jeu de pouce moussu oui
c'est tout ce que je voulais dire oui
voilà tu es sûr que tu ne veux pas
encore un petit peu de limonade après 20
comme ça je crois aussi que ça va très
bien comme ça ça lui réussit pas là
libel 14 jan gehl s'il te plaît
là là toi fabrice vial jouer avec moi là
c'est facile la musique tubes et a tenté
d'y saluer cen sad
[Musique]
je sais je veux dire une chose bell bell
il ya des moments du swing
formidablement ce une page de fabry
quand même un côté disco endettement
disque ou très faible part nous allons
essayer de faire notre petit jeu des
notes de musique
je suis essayé car je me sens
terriblement thing et comment je suis
terriblement thing ah oui tu voudrais
dire fatigué je vais donc la lettre face
sur la porte et faisait gris oui j'ai
commis une imprudence dimanche dernier
je suis allé passer une journée au bord
de la mer et à cause du soleil
j'attrape une à son une insolation
voilà sans la lettre sans les relations
je suis mais théologie sur le sable et
je me suis endormi quand je me suis
réveillé je ne me sentais pas bien j'ai
tremblé j'avais de la fièvre
alors je me suis précipitée suite sa
fille pitt et chippis t as ici
parfaitement précipité witty pharma
comment dans une pharmacie
je recommence sa masse et oui dans une
pharmacie comme tu l'as vu ma tête
le famas ya une l'air complètement est
toujours bien hâte de la trouver il a eu
l'air et atx atx ou et quoi et bailly
et sans rien trouver à railler il n'a
pas six fois cela m'a mise à l'arrêt oui
alors il m'a tout de suite apporté un
verre de deux pas de quoi un verre d'eau
un verre d'eau un verbe des cachets il
m'a dit d'aller me mettre au lit il
avait raison c'était le meilleur qui
chaussent thème systèmes cs ricimer être
six décès y avait un monde fou ce qui ne
me convient pas du tout car j'aime l'art
études tu aimes la la itunes la finitude
louis l'aca à la solitude moins flambard
dc dc c'est la halle et viendra chanter
je suis chaud que ça ira mieux appeler
je crois parce que là ça n'était
vraiment pas quoi mais qui va de toutes
parts fatigué ça m'a mise tout à fait en
bonne état
j'arrive tout de suite et a links à ça
déjà mis les quatre ça ne vous diront
qu'il serait de l'avis majeur s'est
désisté et rzeszow fait des choses mais
comme juni fattoumi noir il faut pas
faire attention les caps a mis son
groupe en abaissant unis les caps a ni
sont heureux car ils aiment la vie
oui
g
[Musique]
et non halal mais gagner ça qui nous
invite à jouer aujourd'hui
il s'y voit revenir à ça me dit vouloir
devenir amis
c'est vrai
[Musique]